Bruno Coppola who is a Brazilian  grizzly signing to a multi-year deal  after a couple of ten-day contracts and  Bradley Beal answers with a three  pointer which can score a hundred or  more they should get the victory and  we'll see what happened it was the most  points they've given up this entire  season Beal and the baseline good that's  his third three-pointer he's made all  three of his attempts from distance he's  known as a defensive player but he can  hit that shot to be his jumper or how  about that just stopped the big man in  his tracks Beal for a wide-open three  nothing but net but points down to take  the lead and then relinquished it on a  final second shot at the quarter here's  Beal again so that gives in six  three-pointers after making the long  ball Wizards have their largest lead and  lentsoe Beal is okay seconds left in the  third quarter Bradley Beal putting them  up knocking them down check out that  pass  did you see Jeff rifle that pass across  the court